you never know what you're gonna find in
the Sheikh Glaser mailbag at the
athletic comm that's something that he
does throughout the offseason last year
one of the Nuggets buried in there was
that he predicted Odell Beckham jr.
would be traded by the Giants people
went crazy and then Odell Beckham jr.
was traded by the Giants this time
around as it relates to the Giants Jay
Glazer suggesting that Dave gentlemen
has one year to turn the team around and
if it doesn't happen he'll be gone and
rightfully so that's the quote from
Blazers article and Chris here's my
concern about this when they hire Joe
judges the coach to replace Pats Shermer
and they gave judge I think a five-year
deal with the goal of ensuring that they
don't fire him after one or two years
the problem is if you fire the GM and
you hire a new GM for next year the new
GM's gonna want his own coach and unless
the new GM had plotted for years to
number 1 become a GM and number 2 when I
do become a GM the first guy I'm hiring
is Joe judge that 2021 season is going
to be all about laying the foundation to
fire Joe judge and hire somebody else so
I don't like it when teams get on these
off schedule arrange where you get a new
coach with the old GM then you get a new
GM
with the old coach and the new GM is in
charge and before you know it there's
gonna be another new coach and then
another GM just give her to everybody
and start over again that's the way to
do it wipe the slate clean and that's
what if the Giants are thinking
gentleman's on the hot seat
this year they should have fired him
when they fire patch Shermer and gotten
a new GM and a new head coach all at
once well I you know I think that was
the common thought last year that both
would be gone but obviously Dave
gentlemen made his plea to ownership and
the other people that are in power there
with the New York Giants the Tisch
family the Mehra family and and stated
his case that he didn't think he
deserved to be you know I fall in the
situation you know again listen Pat
Shermer was not great didn't always do
himself justice by the way he acted at
press conferences I don't think endeared
himself to the media or the fan base
here
you know Gettleman you know it's been
very up and down it's been a rocky road
there's been some moves you look
got you go oh I like it okay you know
there's there's a few draft picks you've
liked but there's been other moves where
you just go that's insane and and of
course you know two years to build a
football team is not that long this day
and age so I don't think this comes as a
shock I kind of looked at this all along
going this is a big draft for Dave
gentlemen this is a big year for the
Giants organization in general but I
expected Dave gentlemen to be on the hot
seat if things didn't go well in New
York yeah and and I don't disagree with
that I just think that and and yeah you
made the point that Glazer made that he
he went in and argued for himself and
and got one look at some point that's
what always a strength of its can but
you've got to have strength of its can
your convictions right you got it you
got to be able to look at this and say
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute we stink and we have stunk for
the past several years and we're getting
a new coach anyway and if we fire Dave
gentlemen after one year we have a mess
in 2021 because then we're gonna go out
and get a GM and say to that GM here's
your coach even if that's not a coach
you would hire and the Giants
traditionally have a strong GM model
where the GM supervises and ultimately
hires and fires the coach so I don't I
just don't like any of this and and I
continue and I'm gonna be as tactful as
I can tell I am I even bothering to try
I feel like John Mara is way too
involved with this team and he tries to
act like he's not and at some point you
just got a lot you got to hire somebody
that you trust and you just gotta let
them run the show and and you gotta just
because you've owned the team for all
these years doesn't mean that all of a
sudden you know how to make all the
right moves and I know Jerry Jones
thinks that that he can do that because
he's on the Cowboys for 30 years and he
made himself the GM from day one but I
just I think that at some point you've
just got to take a step back I just feel
like there's been a little too much
behind the scenes meddling by ownership
in the Giants in recent years do you
agree or disagree well I disagree I
think that they've always been like that
you know they're it's a family business
that's the way they are I mean you know
it's just I listen I'm biased here I
know the family they're great people you
know like you if you owned a football
team you
no I know but if you want to poop on
team you'd have your nose and everything
too so I think you could relate to it a
little bit New York will be back at the
FP after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports